five leaders I want to explore that
mountain in that Valley no we can't
afford to send you out there now we have
to solve the cave problems first before
anyone leaves the cave we laugh at that
that's an absurd claim to make in
caveman days I don't know if anyone did
it but that's a crazy thought because
their solutions to your problems that
might exist and time has demonstrated
likely exist by leaving the cave that
you can then discover so for me exploits
is not just space all the frontiers of
the unknown biology chemistry a I accept
you know those frontiers and then you
can cross pollinate them and transform
civilization and then the last example I
give then I'll shut up cuz I want to
hear you talk to I don't I want to hear
you interact with what I'm telling
here's one you ready okay my physics
professor in college study the universe
love the universe study gas clouds
between stars and studied how would you
detect a gas cloud if it's not radiating
light well they give off radio waves all
right and he figured out what kind of
radio waves they give off and why and in
this he gained expertise in the nucleus
of the atom and he discovered that the
nucleus can resonate depending on the
mass of the nucleus it will which means
depending on what atom it is on the
periodic table it will resonate slightly
differently when exposed to the same
electromagnetic field he discovered a
new phenomenon in physics called nuclear
magnetic resonance they would then take
a clever medical technologist to say
wait a minute if you can distinguish one
heavy atom from another let me make a
machine out of that put your body in it
and I can then distinguish one kind of
tissue from another and thus was born
the magnetic resonance imager the MRI
arguably the most potent tool in the
arsenal of modern medicine where I can
diagnose a condition in your body
without cutting
open first that is based on a principle
of physics discovered by a physicist who
had no interest in medicine by the way
the real title should be nuclear
magnetic resonance imaging but that's
the other N word you're not so you don't
like yet people don't like nuclear the
less likely to go inside the machine if
the word nuclear was on it but my my
point is that was a cross-pollination of
ideas with clever people on their
frontiers looking over the fence at
discoveries that are being made it's how
we got the microwave oven that wasn't
invented by a thermodynamic system I CRO
waves this is a world war two attempt to
communicate using microwaves and they
found out some guys chocolate bar melted
in the microwave field and they said
what do a pan there and they did some
more tests and of course the water
molecule and other molecules common in
food respond to microwaves it vibrates
them ferociously and so you put food in
a microwave cavity the water content of
the food vibrates friction cooks the
food there's still people who today we
say Oh nucleus because I think it's so
fast and they have no fear it's just
friction okay friction it yeah and
everybody's scared that it [ __ ] up the
food well does it no it's just it just
heats the water who gets scared the
woohoo people do okay so here's the
thing there's certain foods that don't
respond well to the flipping of the
water molecule and one of them is like
bread products it's hard yeah it gets
chewy and leathery yeah and only if you
like overdo if you know what you got to
do it just right and you're still good
if you overdo it you can get led that's
kind of it I'm trying to think you
wouldn't grill a steak in a microwave
you would heat up the meat uniformly and
that's that's all it would do cooks
bacon pretty fast yeah but it's a mess
and it splatters all over so you picked
the foods that are best for that
situation as you would pick the food's
best you wouldn't you wouldn't put toast
in an oven at 350 degrees to bread to
make toast
we have toasters for that right so
different things in your kitchen do
things best you wouldn't make ice cream
and you're you know and you spin your
toaster oven people were afraid of
microwaves the one thing they're afraid
of it's not it's not as they're afraid
of microwaves that they're afraid that
of things they don't understand
they're afraid that something's gonna
happen to their food that makes it less
good correct and it's just it's it's
nothing not knowing that people fear my
wife's friend's mom will not eat
something that comes out of a microwave
really she quotes that as part of what
makes her healthy it drinks a lot of
water she refuses to eat microwave food
the whole life is around not using
microwave she won't eat anything that
comes out of her Michael okay I'm glad
that she doesn't you know she'll she can
live a long happy life as such to reheat
food old-school okay one of the hardest
thing is reheating lasagna if you don't
have a microwave Oh true that's like
impostor you gonna cook it again you're
gonna cook it again yeah that's a really
good point so I think microwave ovens
were invented for leftover lasagna mmm
yeah just a bowl of pasta just in
general yeah
soup yes sweet for soup was good yeah so
you don't have to worry about it it's
not doing anything to it it's not not
sucking any nutrients out or adding any
nuclear radiation correct okay there's
nothing with radiation than the normal
sense other than electromagnetic
radiation it's already light from the
bulb we tend to use radiation in the
context of stuff that would hurt you so
that would be radiation of high enough
energy to hurt you and microwaves are
not in that category I never even
thought about what microwaves do until
this conversation really yeah yeah so
it's a certain frequency of microwaves
that beautifully pairs with the water
molecule and it vibrates it brilliantly
so it doesn't work for completely dried
things
yeah that's why if you put something
that has no water in it it's not really
very useful it happens it's white Yves
turkey it's there's still some moisture
in it correct it's why it heats the food
and not the plate
if the plate gets hot it's not because
the microwave oven heated the plate it's
because the foods hit the food and the
food that's why I can usually pick it up
at the handles you can put food on a
paper plate that's right
it doesn't burst a flame doesn't burst
into flame this is crazy
you didn't Joe